former Clinton pollster advisor of Mark
Pen California Congressman darrell ice
at Fox News contributor Tammy Bruce good
to see you all
congressman I see you were in there
hopefully we'll get the transcript
tomorrow I just went over the problems
with these FISA applications is it true
the bulk of information came from the
dossier that Christopher Steele doesn't
even stand by
that's exactly right that it not only
came from the dossier but as you know
Christopher Steele hasn't been in in
Russia in 20 years so even the people
the unknown people responsible for it
could easily easily have in fact been
agents of the Russian government which
would mean that Hillary Clinton is the
one guilty of the so-called collusion
well that's a great irony there you have
been very critical mark pen of this
process from from the get-go here as you
should be I don't I believe if we have a
dual justice system I'm looking at taxi
medallions I'm looking at loan
applications I'm looking at tax
violations I'm not seeing any collusion
here at all this has gone so far but I
do see issues with Russia with uranium
one and that is that we had a spy within
that network and we did have a lot of
money kickback in the end then I do see
issues with this dossier because it's
full of Russian lies and the FBI used it
as the basis of the FISA applications
and in fact they never verified it what
James Comey just said is false
because we know they didn't verify it
because steel doesn't stand by it
well I typically urge all Americans to
read the dossier because anyone who
actually reads the dossier understands
that it's a it's a joke document it's a
document filled with nonsense that
couldn't possibly be true that almost
reads like an April Fool's joke and now
that we've spent you know I don't know
30 million dollars you know investigated
almost everyone in the campaign and the
administration there's still no evidence
of anything that one would call
collusion and certainly not related to
the individual case if anything we're
drifting more and more back to Monica
Lewinsky days by talking about payments
Daniel's and trying to take payments
that are clearly not you know
campaign-related under the definitions
that have been ruled by the FEC and try
to turn those into crimes that you
associate the president with it's that
whole creep of the Special Counsel to
get the president all over again and
Tammy it seems the great Jared explained
it very well in terms of the law and I
watched the history on TV in the same
campaign finance violations well I've
got campaign violations from ninety six
over here and from two thousand eight
over here and from Bob Dole over here
and from Al Gore over here and the
biggest fine paid by Obama my question
to you is as you look at where this is
now gone I mean I feel bad for the men
involved in the things that happen but I
feel that they're victims of what is
selective prosecution and a political
witch-hunt that they got caught up and
by no other reason that they like Donald
Trump well look this is why we're we're
nervous when there's more regulations
and more laws because we pretty much
wake up in the morning as Americans and
we're breaking some kind of a law but
then it's selective about how it gets
applied but it's always kind of hovering
over you this entire dynamic ranging
from the dossier to what catherine
herridge described about their writing
and in the filing that they just did is
fan fiction and we're talking about
criminal justice reform on one hand from
the the Trump administration of course
and the American people see this fraud
this hoax being unleashed upon people in
Washington but we experience it also at
the local level in our daily lives
whether it's the disenfranchised or
people of color this is a very chilling
event Americans recognize it they do not
like it and it's up to the President to
make sure this dynamic growing it's
clear to the American people about
what's happening to them he could still
release the applications the gang of
eight information the 302s and the email
chain do you believe last question
Darryl Isis
we just had comments from James Comey do
you believe what he said about the FISA
warrants was accurate or did he lie well
he's certainly inaccurate the idea that
these things were anything other than
fall
we granted based on deceiving a federal
judge is lat is more laughable than what
Mark said about the dossier itself
ultimately this dossier is what got them
into a business of looking for a crime
that didn't happen
unbelievable I thank you all